que signifie pour vous le mot vacances
qu'elle rêve évoque-t-il je voudrais
d'abord me reposer ensuite voyagé pour
étudier sur un sujet que je ne peux pas
faire ici mais pour moi c'est une
évasion quelque chose qui rompt avec la
monotonie et puis j'ai découvert des
choses nouvelles tout en vous amusant et
bien pour moi les vacances si si j'ai
pas de moyens ça évoque la nécessité
pour moi de travailler en attendant la
bourse de l'année prochaine et si je
trouve les moyens suffisants bien de
voyager pour connaître des oies mais et
des pays je ne peux pas rencontrer
pendant l'année scolaire
on va l'arrêt complet du travail et
qu'elle rêve il évoque pas partir en
vacances au bord de la mer se reposer je
suis machinistes alors pour moi les
vacances c'est un arrêt absolu une
détente au bord de la mer à repos
complet réaliserez vous ce rêve et
comment je devrais je le réalise récit
je trouve un peu d'argent pour le faire
je le réaliserai si possible avec des
camarades trois ou quatre camarades
c'est la formule la plus intéressante
dans la petite et autres cours à cause
d'un manque d'argent
cette année j'ai fait le projet d'aller
faire un voyage en algérie et le des
camarades et de tourner un film mais je
pense que je pouvais de réaliser suivant
mes moyens
est-ce que vous réaliserez ce rêve oui
j'espère comment cheval en vacances en
bretagne
je pense que oui je réaliserai ce rêve
bien que c'est pas encore sûr faut
étudier les moyens de locomotion quand
va t'on pense partir explique avec
plusieurs camarades en voiture non car
heureusement valeur le mois de septembre
mes moyens de me permettent pas je les
ai connus mire peux pas me permettre et
où irez-vous en vacances cette année je
voudrais à prague parce que à marienbad
parce que je m'intéresse au maroc cet
été l'année dernière je voulais plutôt
voir la renaissance italienne alors cela
florence peut-être yougoslavie on fera
un camp itinérant le long de la côte
dalmate on bat surtout nos vacances sur
le camping et le sport nous partons en
espagne comme d'habitude
alors si vous allez en vacances vous
irez en groupe
seul j'irais plutôt avec quelques amis
en groupe lui 1,3 en amp en famille ou
en groupe
un petit mot 3 4 maximum et quand est
absolument tout seul je suis
certainement à l'ethnie par les combats
pourquoi
sketches transgene ils veulent pas
chamakh un succès voici une équipe de
jeunes les uns sont métallos les autres
employés de bureau ou étudiants le
travail c'est bien les vacances c'est
mieux
nous leur avons demandé comment il
occupait ses vacances jean-marie comment
elle vous l'intention de passer vos
vacances dans le plus joyeusement
possible ce que façon je puisse me
relaxer un peu et où allez vous voulez
passer ses vacances sur shane x je vais
dans le maine-et-loire avec un camarade
elle vous partez comment on part en
mobylette tous les deux quelle formule
avez vous choisi on a choisi le camping
cette année je ne prends pas de vacances
pourquoi et bien pour la simple raison
que je pars au service militaire au mois
de septembre et que coûte rooney vous
considérez que le service militaire ce
sont des vacances
non mais je crois qu'il vente ou faut
penser à partir avec un peu d'argent
et quand on s'est bien amusés pendant
toute une année quand arrive le moment
d'aller au service militaire il faut
penser avoir un peu d'argent voilà c'est
pour savoir pendant les vacances je
travaille c'est tellement
marie-françoise vous êtes étudiante
oui en quoi je fais mes études
d'infirmière pensez vous que vous avez
mérité des vacances
c'est un travail fatigant mais je pense
je moi je
j'ai décidé de travailler pendant les
vacances combien de temps allez-vous en
vacances nous avons qu'un mois vous
allez où je vais faire une colonie et je
vais aller à soulac
enfin c'est juste en dessous de royan
cette année j'ai choisi de la berck
plage
mais vous allez dans votre famille tous
les ans non la dernière je suis allé en
espagne avec colony des cuma pourquoi
cette année allez vous en famille parce
que les économies sont faibles vous
comptez sur la famille pour vous pour
m'aider
françoise que faites vous de vos
vacances moi j'ai un problème un peu
particulier en ce sens que j'ai trois
mois de vacances
alors pour ces vacances prochaine ni
rien de très vifs encore je pense
travailler trouver un job pour un mois
de travail pour un mois kouassi les
gagner un peu d'argent pour me permettre
après être passé un mois
de vraies vacances au lac ce faisant pas
mal de sport de bateaux de natation
enfin les vacances avec un grand v comme
on les voit habituellement quoi je le
devine que faites vous dans la vie je
suis secrétaire
vous avez donc droit à un mois de congé
oui comment allez-vous profiter de ce
congé enfin je n'ai que trois semaines
car j'ai déjà pris une semaine au mois
d'avril je suis parti en allemagne avec
la maison des jeunes et pendant les
trois semaines je pas au lycée dure aux
baléares après une enquête qui a été
fait dans les maisons des jeunes du
département qui s'est tapé le tiercé du
voyage et j'ai choisi les bayards
natacha que faites vous pendant vos
vacances dans un camping
c'est en effet originale de travailler
pendant les vacances
pour quelles raisons ont travaillé vous
en plus de l'originalité
ce qu'il faut de l'argent pour gagner
[Musique]